ces habitants de karkhiv ont tout perdu
leur appartement est en ruine après ce
dernier bombardement
je vivais ici avec ma famille ma femme
et mes deux enfants dont un handicapé de
satin ça c'était ma porte d'entrée
près de six mois après le début de
l'invasion de l'ukraine les forces
russes n'ont toujours pas réussi à
prendre le contrôle de karkhiv la
deuxième ville d'ukraine est constamment
pilonné et les bombardements se sont
intensifiés ces derniers jours
conséquence de plus en plus de victimes
si vite dans cette ville où la
population est majoritairement
russophone
vraiment je dis merci à poutine pour une
telle vie à un âge avancé j'ai 73 ans et
il a bombardé l'appartement seigneur
pourquoi cette punition pourquoi nous
font-ils cela
les missiles russes ont touché des
dizaines de résidents ces derniers jours
moscou ni avoir visé des civils et
prétend avoir bombardé une base de
mercenaires ukrainien une journée de
deuil est prévue ce vendredi à kharkiv
pour rendre hommage aux victimes